[Music]
[Music]
hello there
general i didn't have a whole lot of
time to make a big production video this
weekend
given the fact that i'm still playing
the game as well as some other projects
i have to take care of as well but i
still wanted to present
something to hold you over until i get
around to the bigger stuff
so here's a smaller video covering some
of my findings during my playthrough of
age of calamity so far
this includes little bits of lore
secrets or any other things i found
interesting or peculiar
so let's get started
[Music]
one thing that has eluded us in the
backstory of breath the wild is how
exactly the guardians were found
in one of the first cutscenes of the
game told to us by king rome's spirit we
see some chica researchers digging in
gerudo canyon
after which it shows divine beast vana
boris being discovered embedded in the
sandstone
moments later we see more scientists
standing amidst a group of guardian
stalkers which they dug up as well
however rome never specifies where
exactly these were found
i think most of us assumed that they
were found underneath hyrule castle
since in one of the underground chambers
we find small groups of these machines
still half buried however age of
calamity gives us more insight into some
of the locations the guardians were
discovered as well as the sheer number
of them
apparently the biggest sites of these
excavations were the breach of demise
and the area surrounding oculus citadel
and yes according to the game it's
actually pronounced
accola not akala as many of us assumed
the game shows us just how large these
excavation projects really were
and even how they were dug up upon
discovery they used wooden cranes and
pulleys to extract them from the ground
after which they were likely transported
to either hyrule castle or the royal
ancient tech lab
another interesting detail regarding the
excavations of the relics is that we
finally have confirmation that the
stalkers
were not the only type of guardians
being dug up i actually missed this
during my playthrough of the demo
in the second story mission which takes
place inside the breach of demise
we can find recently dug up guardian sky
watchers
this is a great piece of exhibition
since before age of calamity it has
always been
unclear where exactly the sky watchers
and other guardian types came from
and i think most of us speculated that
they were stored inside the giant column
surrounding hyrule castle
while theorizing about these rumored
columns zelda mentions in her research
notes that these giants may hold even
more guardian types
this made a lot of us assume that they
probably didn't dig up
any of the other types of guardians just
the stalkers
and that the rest emerged from the
columns later but nope they
actually did find other types as well
zelda may have just been speculating
that there were even more types aside
from the ones they already found
this next one is a very minor detail and
i think plenty of you
already figured this one out on your own
during the first mission on death
mountain we eventually come across
the goron hot springs the rook suggests
that we should rest our wary bones here
for a while
if you step into the water of the hot
springs your hearts will replenish one
by one the longer you stay inside
it works exactly the same as it did in
breath of the wild
here too when you stand inside the warm
waters of the hot spring
the same thing happens i think it's nice
to see that they carried this mechanic
over
a little detail that helps tie the games
together
another significant revelation is that
the hylians
due to the efforts of the chica no doubt
actually had access to
portable ancient furnaces the game
refers to them as
simple furnaces and their design
strongly resembles that of the larger
ancient furnaces found in the cluda and
akala
i mean akula this is gonna get some
getting used to
anyway this is a neat little detail it's
obvious that the ancient furnaces were
not built by the modern day chica but
rather discovered and unearthed just
like the other relics so those are the
handiwork of the ancient chica from ten
thousand years ago
the modern-day sheikah likely copied its
design and created small portable
versions of these furnaces
this way they would have access to
ancient energy anywhere they deployed
them
i really like this idea a lot and it
shows just how resourceful the chica
were
copying the designs of their distant
ancestors and turning them into
something new
it's also worth mentioning that aside
from the fact that hyrule castle and the
royal ancient tech lab were the heart of
the sheikah
research the game reveals that these
were not the only locations where
research was conducted
all throughout the breach of the mice
and close to akla citadel we can find
smaller temporary labs
these house all kinds of notes formulas
written on chalkboards
guardian parts and in some cases these
portable furnaces
we also see that some guardians after
being dug up were assembled cleaned and
made operational directly on site
zelda even mentions in one instance in
front of the citadel
that this place used to have a research
lab indicating that these labs were set
up and then dismantled again once the
research was concluded
the queen of hyrule who is said to have
died unexpectedly when zelda was around
the age of 6
has been a subject of debate and mystery
ever since breath the wild
she is spoken about in zelda and king
rome's diaries and is also mentioned
briefly on certain pages in masterworks
but her actual appearance has always
eluded us
in breath of the wild's hyrule castle
more specifically in king rome's secret
room where his diary is
we find a picture ripped from its frame
now some of us speculated that this
might have been a picture of rome and
his wife
we can actually visit this area in age
of calamity as well
and nope it's just a picture of a
landscape
well played nintendo now here's where i
have to show you something from the late
game but don't worry i only show a still
frame and i've removed any other
contacts from the image so it doesn't
really spoil anything in regards to the
main story itself
still if you want to be surprised you
can skip to the time code presented at
the bottom of the screen
alright 3 2 1 ready set go
darth vader is luke's father also
during zelda's last memory from when she
was a child she calls out to her mother
and then she turns around we are then
presented with
this the first time we actually see
zelda's mother in the flesh
but of course in true nintendo fashion
we never see her actual face
right as the camera is about to face her
the screen dips to white
the only thing we can really derive from
this is that she's wearing the same
clothing
zelda is seen wearing in some of the
memories from breath of the wild
as well as some cut scenes in age of
calamity this is the getup she garnishes
mainly when she's present at hyrule
castle or during any formal event
nice to know but still doesn't really
reveal much about the queen
unfortunately but there is one location
where we actually get
another tip of the veil regarding
hyrule's late queen
ever since breath of the wild there's
one important area
inside hyrule castle that has been
hidden from us this room is described
and even depicted in masterworks as
the great hall of which its entrance has
collapsed
due to the events of the calamity thus
making it inaccessible in the actual
game
well in age of calamity we actually get
to visit this location as well
and it's great to see this place finally
realized in game
a grand chapel-like interior decorated
with arches
fire pits statues of knights and draped
with banners depicting the famous crest
of the triforce in loftwing also found
on the hylian shield
more interestingly however in the very
back of the hall we find a statue of two
figures
a man and a woman the man is undoubtedly
king rome himself in his younger years
before he became a football this is
given away by the hair
the clothing as well as the pose of the
statue so by that definition that would
make the figure standing next to him
his wife the queen of hyrule aka zelda's
mother
making this the first and only full
depiction of her
of course the statue itself is still
relatively low poly
and the lighting doesn't exactly help to
see any finer details
but it's still nice that they actually
included this in the game
when i showed this picture to conrad of
the commonwealth realm he noted that the
statue is likely a memorial to their
wedding
and the pose the queen strikes also
looks familiar
it's something we've seen all throughout
the zelda series which usually has some
kind of connection to the divine
whether being to the goddess hylia or
the three golden goddesses who created
the world
praying to them and requesting their
support or showing your devotion to them
in some way
this hints that zelda's mom did have a
connection to the gods the divine or
maybe even the sacred realm in some way
after all
i'm saying after all because this isn't
something we've known for sure
this last one is more of a funny little
detail in breath of the wild
link wasn't exactly the most fleshed out
character partly due to the fact that he
had amnesia
and even the memories we can unlock that
feature him don't really show a whole
lot more than the fact that he was
zelda's knight and that he was
brave and always silent we do see that
he had a friendship with the rook and
mifa the latter of which may have been a
possible romantic relationship in some
shape or form
and of course his relationship to zelda
which started out rocky but then slowly
grew into something more close
but again it doesn't really show much
beyond this in terms of his character
traits
however in her diary zelda does reveal
some little details about him
one of these revelations is that link is
apparently quite a glutton and that he
cannot resist a delicious meal
so it's nice that they actually depict
this in age of calamity on two different
occasions
i mean with the exception of the wind
waker link has generally always been
kind of a blank slate since we're
supposed to project ourselves onto him
but it's nice to see that they actually
show this part of his personality
it just makes him feel more like a real
person despite the fact that he doesn't
speak
and that is all for now i hope to start
creating some bigger theories very soon
but for now i'm mostly gonna
focus on the experience of the game and
not rush through it i really enjoy all
these little backstories and lore
exposition
so i definitely don't wanna skip over
anything a shout out goes to walters
equal
a new member who i forgot to mention in
my last video and ira who recently
joined my patreon
and of course a big thanks to all of you
who support and watch my videos
i will see you all in the next one this
is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
you